AGAINST THE ARIZONA TEAM THE WAY
THEY'V
VICTORIA, BC.
HERE'S THE INTRIGUING LINE TS TE
CORNER TO GETKAMPF GOT HELD UP O
REACH FOR THE REBOUND.
ENGVALL AFTER IT.
HE WAS SHOOTING.
HERE EARLY ON FOR SHELDON KEEFE.
WE SAW SIMILAR PLAY, NYLANDEROOK
AND FINDS IT IN THEIRST
PERIOD.
HERE'S A CHANCE IN FRONT, AND WD
BUNTING TO THE FRONT OF THE NET
TO KEEP THAT ONE OUT.
>> Chris: NICK SCHMA BY
SCHMALTZ.
JUST DANCES IN ALONE AND ON THE.
ALONG WITH MOSER.
MATTHEWS BEH
WINDING UP IS MIKHEYEV.
ILYA MIKHEYEV
ENGVALL INSIDE POSITION THERE ON
MAYO.
SEE IF IT'S
ANYTHING HEALTH-WISE OR IF IT'S.
T.J. BRODIE MOVED UP.
ROBERTSON BACK CREATES
ALL KINDS OF ROOM, AND IN ALL B.
>> Craig: THE SHOCKING THE LINE.
MORGAN RIELLY GETS KNOCKED DOWN
IN FRONT SO HE STAYS.
BEHIND-THE-BACK PASS AHEAD.
AND AUSTON MATTHEWEW
MATTHEWS ANOTHER.
NOW GOOD BATTLE FOR THAT LOOSE
PUCK.
"D" TO "D." RICOCHETED TO KAMPFW
TAKING OVER IS ENGVALL. LEAD.
>> HOW ABOUT THAT FOR WEDGEWOOD.
TALK ABOUT DIGGING IN.
THIS YEAR.
LYUBUSHK FOR A
GOALTENDER WITH ALL THE OPEN
ICE.RM.
NOW MARNER
WITH HOLL.
MITCH MARNER TOOK A